à alors que le sénat a été
particulièrement malmenée dans les
médias récemment le président va revenir
sur l'image du sénat et le rôle qu'il
doit incarner aujourd'hui une opposition
constructive selon les mots de gérard
larcher on écoute suite le président
notre session est maintenant commencée
la semaine passée nous avons examiné un
texte important
sur la lutte contre le terrorisme nous
l'avons adopté
la semaine prochaine
nous débuterons l'examen en deuxième
lecture du projet de loi sur la
délimitation des régions nous voici à la
tâche
le 28 septembre
c'est une nouvelle majorité que les
délégués sénatoriaux ont choisi pour
notre haute assemblée pour moi leur vote
est l'expression d'une confiance dans le
sénat
et cette confiance mes chers collègues
nous oblige tous
sénatrices et sénateurs
majorité comme opposition
car au delà de nos différences de nos
divergences de nos parcours c'est le
même constat que nous partageons il faut
relever le sénat et agir concrètement
pour faire vivre le bicamérisme
c'est l'esprit de la feuille de route
que je vous propose de suivre ensemble
nous les 348 sénateurs pour se résumer
en un mot le mot confiance
le sénat est le reflet nos territoires
mais au delà il incarne la nation la
nation avec ses différences et sa
diversité la nation avec ses valeurs et
son unité mais pour moi la nation est un
tout
vous savez la france doute la politique
est en crise mais j'en rajouterai pas
même si c'est la mode y compris
littéraire
notre responsabilité est collective car
quand il s'agit de la france c'est de
l'intérêt du pays et du pays seuls
c'est cet intérêt qui doit guider notre
action
ce n'est donc pas la faire d'un seul
camp il est l'impératif de tous
majorité et opposition doivent se
retrouver sur cet objectif nous devons
être l'assemblée de l'élan collectif et
agir ensemble
l'opposition est essentielle à la vie
d'une démocratie mais elle n'est utile
au pays que si elle s'inscrit bien
entendu dans une démarche de
construction
les français nous observe et il nous
jugeront sur notre capacité à nous
mobiliser face à l'ampleur des réformes
à accomplir
les français attendent que leur
représentant et le courage d'assumer des
choix des choix qui peuvent être
difficiles qui parfois bouscule les
clivages qui dépasse les seuls rendez
vous électoraux et les appels à préférer
l'intérêt national sur l'intérêt parfois
corporatiste nous devons être ici le
lieu de la confiance retrouvée entre
élus et citoyens
oui le sénat doit redonner du sens à la
politique il doit tracer des
perspectives d'espoir il doit face aux
tentations du repli communautariste
consolider notre pacte républicain et
réaffirmer les valeurs de laïcité auquel
nous sommes tous attachés nous sénateurs
nous puisons notre force dans notre
ancrage territorial
nous puisons notre crédibilité nationale
à la source de l'expérience locale
et le pouls de la république bat dans
nos territoires
le quinquennat a changé le rythme de
notre démocratie la vème république
fonctionne autour d'un bloc quelque peu
monolithique
l'elysée matignon l'assemblée nationale
ces trois institutions avance d'un même
rythme un rite dont le tempo est donné
par le sommet le seul fera
institutionnels à ce rouleau compresseur
c'est le sénat il est le balancier
stabilisateur des institutions il est la
voix de la différence car il n'est pas
dans le temps du quinquennat il permet
de prendre en compte entre deux
élections présidentielles
les expressions démocratiques locales
c'est ce que nous avons vécu en mars
dernier et le 28 septembre
mais notre légitimité démocratique mais
pas limité à la seule démographie nous
représentons les français au travers de
leur lieu de vie le territoire
nous ressemblons à la france nous sommes
même le principal représentant mes chers
collègues d représentent des territoires
les plus faiblement peuplée des pauvres
en démographie sans nous que pèsera t'il
en terme d'aménagement ou de solidarité
budgétaire de ce point de vue le sénat
garant de la cohésion territoriale
me paraît être un garant de l'unité
nationale
le critère démographique
mes chers collègues et ils le critère
exclusif de représentativité la
démocratie du nombre et celle du
territoire doivent se combiner pour
améliorer la représentation des citoyens
le sénat représente la ruralité et les
espaces urbains et périurbains il est
l'assemblée des territoires ceux de
métropole et d'outre-mer il aura
d'ailleurs une responsabilité
particulière de souveraineté mes chers
collègues avec le rendez vous
législatifs sur la nouvelle calédonie au
cours de ces trois années nous sommes
les porteurs de la diversité
territoriale française il nous faut mes
chers collègues imaginer ensemble un
sénat qui soit aussi hors les murs à
senna qu'ils aillent au devant des
réalités de terrain et dont une part des
travaux pourraient se dérouler en
fonction des sujets dans nos
départements nos régions ou en outre-mer
c'est là aussi que nous sommes attendus
c'est là où nous démontrerons la
proximité de ne pas rassembler avec les
françaises et les français
mes chers collègues je souhaite être un
président qui avec vous tous rassemble
un président fédérateur de la majorité
sénatoriale attentif à chacune et à
chacun de ceux qui la composent mais
aussi un président à l'écouté de toutes
les sénatrices de tous les sénateurs
quelles que soient leurs engagements un
président attentif aux droits de
l'opposition dans sa diversité
c'est maintenant mes chers collègues
qu'il nous faut être imaginatif et
réactif il nous faut être ambitieux pour
le sénat
l'utilité de notre assemblée nous
l'approuverons d'allant au devant des
difficultés
qu'affrontent les élus du territoire et
nos compatriotes
je pense au premier lieu à l'emploi je
sais que chacun d'entre vous dans son
territoire dans sa propre famille est
confronté au fléau du chômage
c'est nous petites et moyennes
entreprises aux très petites entreprises
bien sûr nos grandes
qui s'enracinant dans les communes créer
les emplois il nous faut être à leur
écoute alléger leurs contraintes je vous
ai proposé dans mon projet une nouvelle
délégation dédié aux entreprises sa
création devrait être à l'ordre du jour
d'un prochain bureau je pense également
à l'empilement normatif qui étouffe la
créati créativité décourage l'initiative
dans nos communes et nos départements et
pèse fortement sur nos finances
publiques là aussi je vous ferai des
propositions extrêmement concrètes
extrêmement précises pour que nous
passions du discours de l'incantation
des rapports ou des moratoires à des
décisions concrètes
la france
ne peut plus attendre
l'organisation territoriale mes chers
collègues va constituer l'un des tout
premiers enjeux de nos travaux sur ce
dossier le message que je porte est
simple on ne peut pas raisonnablement
réformer l'organisation territoriale en
ignorant notre assemblée et partant de
ce principe
c'est ce que j'ai dit au président de la
république lorsqu'il m'a accueilli après
mon élection à la présidence je lui ai
fait des propositions pour que nous
ayons nous les sénateurs les moyens de
débattre sereinement de manière
constructive sur les textes territoriaux
dans l'intérêt général du pays le
premier ministre conformément à
l'article 50-1 de notre constitution
pourra donc une déclaration la semaine
prochaine devant notre assemblée sur la
réforme territoriale
elle sera suivie d'un débat qui
précédera l'indispensable deuxième
lecture du projet de loi sur la
délimitation des régions le texte sur la
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
république que le sénat devait
initialement examinée au début novembre
sera lui programmé à la part à partir de
la deuxième quinzaine de décembre nous
aurons le temps de travailler sans excès
de lenteur sans excès de vitesse c'est
cela aussi cette forme d'opposition que
j'appelle de mes voeux
c'est elle qui devra guider nos rapports
avec l'exécutif et l'assemblée nationale
il nous incombe rade apporter à ces
textes la plus-value territoriales du
sénat c'est d'ailleurs pour accroître
notre aptitude à créer ces plus values
que je vous propose de rétablir par
redéploiement de moyens des prestations
d'expertisé de conseils qui vous
permettront de répondre aux questions
des élus locaux qui vous saisissent de
leurs problèmes
relevés le sénat c'est aussi donner plus
de lisibilité à notre action cela passe
par une révision de nos méthodes de
travail et nos outils je vous propose de
mettre en place rapidement un groupe de
travail pluraliste pour faire le bilan
des réformes du règlement bilan des
réformes de 2009 et de 2011 et pour
ouvrir les perspectives
ce groupe devra réfléchir notamment un
meilleur équilibre entre travail en
commissions et travaille en séance
publique et à une meilleure coordination
de nos travaux il faut que nous
puissions établir des agendas plus
cohérent nos actions sur les politiques
publiques à la législation doivent être
plus compréhensive de l'opinion et il
nous faudra imaginer
de nouveaux modes de votation qui nous
permettront de nous retrouver
régulièrement en nombre pour manifester
quelles sont nos choix finaux sur des
textes importants
une autre mesure
pour être mise en oeuvre rapidement
le remplacement des questions cribles
thématiques par des questions cribles
ministériel portant sur l'ensemble des
politiques publiques conduites
notamment par un membre du gouvernement
pour ces questions j'en ai saisi les
présidents de groupes qui devront nous
faire des propositions
en ces matières la conférence des
présidents et le bureau aurons un débat
des préconisations mais c'est au sénat
dans son ensemble qu'il appartiendra
prendre les décisions finales dès qu'il
s'agira d'adapter donc de modifier notre
règlement à l'heure où l'avenir du monde
repose sur des forces économie
globalisée notre rayonnement en europe
doit être une priorité pour moi cela
suppose un dialogue renforcé bien
entendu avec le parlement européen et
les parlements nationaux des principaux
et amant mais je vous le dis
l'europe ne sera
puissante que si la collaboration franco
allemande est renforcée et je pense que
le sénat jouera dans ce domaine toute sa
place et s'engagera
quant à la parole du sénat au delà des
frontières européennes
je la porterai avec notre commission des
affaires étrangères nos autres
commissions en m'appuyant sur nos
collègues représentant les français
établis hors de france
une gouvernance responsable
et une bonne gestion collective
participe aussi de notre ambition nous
adapter à s'étendre contrainte est
nécessaire et exemplaire nous l'avons
déjà montré nous le montrerons et je
vous le dis je ne laisserai pas
caricaturer le sénat et les sénateurs je
vous le dis mes chers collègues je le
dis aussi à nos différents cadres de
fonctionnaires à nos collaborateurs aux
collaborateurs des groupes politiques
servir le sénat de la république doit
être une fierté et une fierté et de ce
point de vue aussi notre administration
placé sous l'autorité des questeurs et
de l'ensemble du bureau doit symboliser
une fonction publique innovantes
exigeante ouverte sur l'extérieur
la confiance retrouvée
de l'opinion implique d'améliorer notre
communication et notamment notre
communication institutionnelle je pense
que le sénat gagnerait à se doter d'un
comité exécutif pluraliste afin de mieux
structurer nos actions de communication
je pense que nos travaux devront avoir
une résonance plus importantes sur les
réseaux sociaux et internet notamment
valorisant l'open data du sénat qui est
une avancée remarquable mais qui doit
être mieux connues
notre action peut emprunter de multiples
canaux sa chose et nous gagnerons cette
bataille pour le sénat par les coupes du
pays par la qualité nos initiatives et
par la force de nos idées
parmi les réflexions tout pouvons avoir
pourquoi ne pas imaginer mais ceci reste
très ouvert en partenariat avec les
professions du droit une fondation de la
loi dont la mission serait d'expliquer
de manière pédagogique ce qu'une
nouvelle législation change dans l'ordre
juridique préexistant
ce temps
chers collègues l'image du sénat perçu
de l'extérieur doit être le reflet de ce
que notre institution est en réalité
c'est comme cela aussi que nous
prouverons son rôle essentiel pour une
république apaisée c'est comme ça que
nos engagements seront tenus chers
collègues je le crois
la république a besoin du sénat nous
avons une responsabilité en ces périodes
de gros temps politique nous devons être
capables de nous rassembler et de
ressembler à la france nous devons être
l'assemblée de la france qui se sent
oublié
abandonné mais aussi celle de la france
de l'innovation des créateurs de
l'excellence et les réussites locales le
peuple français doit retrouver la
confiance confiance en ses élus nous
sommes dépositaires de la légitimité
nationale les valeurs de la république
sont au coeur de mon engagement je suis
sûr qu'elles sont au coeur de
l'engagement de chacune et de chacun
d'entre vous je crois vraiment en mes
chers collègues que le sénat peut tente
apporter à la république et nous allons
en apporter la preuve tous ensemble je
vous remercie
merci
merci voilà vous venez donc puissent
suivre en direct sur notre antenne
l'allocution de gérard larcher on le
sait le président été choqués par les
attaques récentes contre le sénat il
veut donc rétablir l'image de
l'institution il parle d'un sénat qui
redonne du sens à la politique un sénat
qui incarne une opposition constructive
sur la gouvernance donc gérard larcher
va créer un groupe de travail chargé de
faire le bilan des réformes du règlement
interne du sénat il veut aussi mieux
structurer la communication du sénat
gérard larcher a également parlé d'une
fondation de la loi dont le rôle serait
d'expliquer les nouvelles législations
gérard larcher qui a évoqué la réforme
territoriale
il a confirmé le report de l'examen du
projet de loi sur les compétences des
collectivités à fin décembre
autre sujet important le chômage
le président du sénat a annoncé la
création d'une nouvelle délégation aux
entreprises dans l'objectif serait
d'encourager les pme et les tpe dans les
territoires à la création d'emplois
voilà donc pour cette première
allocution du président du sénat